ce soir nos mémoires du zinc sont
consacrés à michael youn alors ne
comptez pas sur moi pour utiliser le
mégaphone sûrement pas sûrement pas
parce que fait un peu trop quand même
rendu à fait à chaque fois et il en a
alors accueilli bonsoir mon sort daniel
alors double actualité
le dvd le pire du morning live on a
cherché le meilleur on l'a pas trouvée
donc on s'est dit qu'on allait mettre le
pire ce serait pousser pour la presse et
pour la pointe une fatal bazooka fous ta
cagoule
alors qu'est ce que nous allons faire
mais moi j'aimerais bien qu'on au regard
d'un beau daniel beauvois là on va
regarder un extrait du clip
fatal bazooka fous ta cagoule année 250
francs 32 qui nous force à mes hommes
étaient au courant qu'on comprend bien
ce que tu dis car si acacias tu as du
mal gré n'est ce pas ça mais on a un
message précis tu vois c'est un
[Musique]
michaël youn qu'est ce que c'est que
cette offre il a d'ailleurs je n'en ai
pas entendu parler au moment où on m'a
dit qu'il y avait une révolution c'est
durable savoyard du hip hop hardcore
venue de savoie et et pousse un grand
cri de rage contre le fléau de cette
société on soit en bien content
aujourd'hui le fléau c'est le froid ce
n'est pas le réchauffement de la planète
comme on essaie de la planète si vous
avez vu le bon film le réchauffement de
la planète en train de plus de froid
le film d'al gore voulait dire
absolument et est donc voilà il donne un
conseil à tous ceux qui veulent pas
choper une rhinopharyngite n'ont eu une
angine un run ou autre tout la cagoule
comme le disait ta maman fous ta cagoule
ouais voilà c'est vrai tout à l'heure
cette histoire de mégaphones c'est un
petit private joke pour vous ça veut
dire mais bon qui nous identifient où
j'en suis extrêmement fier
je suis extrêmement fier mais cirque on
peut pas à chaque fois que je fais une
émission de télé me demander à brax
magie fait fait nous le truc avec le
mégaphone ou gif ou trois poils c'est
marrant mais non gelée déjà fait je vais
pas refaire tout le temps la même chose
puis on est à café picouly ou ne se met
pas tout ce qui a fait le malin toi je
te tire tout cas pas moi un vrai ce que
tu veux alors on va commencer par à
figures libres figures libres qui est
matérialisée par cette petite danseuse
qui font monter un petit peu ce soir
elle est fatiguée et oui elle a vécu
voilà n'est-elle pas charmante
alors cette petite danseuse quels sujets
vous inspire-t-elle j'avais envie de ça
me ressemble pas trop parce qu'on a on
voit plutôt en général déconner mais
j'avais envie de parler de l'état des
prisons en france
en fait la prison à la base qu'est ce
que c'est c'est un endroit où on parle
isolement ou par la solitude forcée
on demande à des gens en impose à des
gens de réfléchir sur ce qu'ils ont fait
afin de s'améliorer en tant qu'être
humain le problème est que quand on est
à dix ou douze dans cinq mètres carrés
on peut pas véritablement réfléchir sur
comment devenir un être humain meilleur
et et je crois qu'avec les discours des
présidentielles qui arrivent sur
toujours la même chose la sécurité le le
chômage etc etc on a tendance à vouloir
faire croire que dans les prisons il ya
que des assassins de grand-mère et que
dès que des serial killers alors que
c'est pas vrai ça c'est que la 1% les
99% c'est des mecs qui ont dérapé comme
moi j'aurais pu déraper peut-être est-ce
parce que vous avez une
une jeunesse qui a été un petit peu
difficile vous avez enfin j'ai jamais
vraiment eu beaucoup de problèmes avec
la justice mais voilà on passe très très
vite de l'autre côté de la barrière
parce qu'on n'a pas réussi tout de suite
avoir les clés de la société et c est
que au lieu que cette prison vous
permettre de réfléchir et de devenir
comme je vous disais un être humain
meyer bass l inverse on va devenir va
devenir quelqu'un de pire parce que les
conditions qui a dans les prisons
françaises aujourd'hui qui amnistie
internationale comparé quand même à des
dictatures fascistes
font qu'on n'arrive pas à s'améliorer il
n'est pas normal qu'un qu'un mec parce
qu'il avait un pas su comment s'en
sortir autrement s'est mis à vendre on
va dire allez je sais pas 250 ou 500
grammes de shit c'est quand même une
bonne partie du jeu on commence mais
c'est pas normal que les deux seules
alternatives que lui propose la société
française ce soit soit le suicide en
prison soit la carte du grand banditisme
donc je crois que est le problème c'est
que tout le monde s'en fout des prisons
les politiques s'en foutent des
primaires quand même la france a été
stigmatisée et condamnés au niveau
européen
c'est ça la france a été stigmatisé mais
ce que les politiques sont je pense que
les politiques sans faute parce que
c'est pas ça qui rapporte des voix parce
que parce que le français aux 1 qui va
toujours dire de façon s'ils sont à
présent c'est qu'ils l'ont bien cherché
vous avez eu envie vous êtes
d'intervenir en prison d'avis passé
c'est qu'à l'époque où je présentais le
morning live les prisonniers soient un
petit peu comme les ouvriers ce sont des
gens qui se lèvent très tôt et donc on
retrouve énormément de courrier de jean
qui était au placard et qui nous faisait
merci merci beaucoup pour ce que vous
faites et ça ça nous avait vachement
touchée à l'époque de voir que d'un
conte était un petit peu pour certaines
personnes le la petite manivelle qui
leur remonter le moral et que et que à
part à part leur petite télé c'est pour
ça d'où l'importance aussi d'avoir la
télé parfois en prison aussi parce que
c'était là leur seule source d'espoir
leur seul vent de liberté
d'accord je crois qu'on a on a compris
au début me disiez c'est un sujet qui me
ressemble pas mais aussi pourquoi
est-ce-que enfermement à l'enfermement
ses médailles majorité des retraités
c'est vous trouvez pas ce que j'ai vu
hier je n'ai pas l'habitude on ne voit
pas vous parlez souvent saint-servan à
la télévision parce que parce que le le
prisme cathodique est un miroir
déformant et souvent dit qu'on n'est pas
là pour s'exprimer sincèrement mais ça
dépend des émissions ou bien écouter
lève ma petite danseuse est très content
que de ce moment de sincérité je lui
merci beaucoup
alors ping-pong maintenant à allah on va
bien rigoler on évoquait l'idée qu'il y
aurait pu avoir mais alors de façon très
discrète quelques petites critiques soit
dit en passant c'est saint céré dossier
je donne
j'ai le dos les yeux il contient de quoi
débattre un peu alors ses mérites d'un
jour ce qu'on dit qu'on potter qui est
drôle avec les critiques c'est que par
exemple quand on sort un film 6 à 99
critiques positives et négatives on va
retenir que c'est le québec est négative
moi malheureusement c'est souffre et l
inverse
je reconnais que la positive parce qu'il
y avait eu que des critiques négatives
le truc c'est que avec les critiques des
journalistes c'est c'est toujours la
même chose on sait que ce n'est la vie
que d'une seule personne de celui qui
écrit le papier mais pourtant ça fait
mal ça fait de la peine moi je compare
souvent ça aux dentistes les problèmes
de danser jamais grave mais toujours ça
fait mal
donc moi c'est pour ça que j'ai pu
réagir parfois avec beaucoup de
virulence aux différentes critiques j'ai
par exemple ou de trois ans de suite le
gérard du plus mauvais acteur français
la première fois ses pairs de saisir
ça m'a vraiment fait de la peine je
trouvais ça injuste je me disais j'étais
sûr qu'un avait des poumons avec moi
cette année là j'avais des noms deuxième
année consécutivement je me dis là ok là
c'est la preuve que c'est une cabale
mon voeu voilà ils en veulent c'est de
l'acharnement et la troisième année eh
ben je me suis surpris moi même a à dire
ben écoutez je me félicite pour ma
régularité dans dans le non choix de mes
projets dans mon jeu d'acteur et
j'espère que l'année prochaine encore je
serai aussi régulier dans mon nouveau
parfum d honneur au cinéma français d'un
autre côté daniel si je dois être
sincère avec vous c'est la soirée c'est
que avec la personnalité provocante et
si vous voulez entre guillemets le le le
ce qu'ils appellent le fonds de commerce
que j'ai il est normal que les
journalistes le lendemain en caressant
gentiment derrière la nuque
le gie donc je trouve aussi que c'est un
juste retour des choses évidemment
et qui c'est qui va arranger le gros
dossier c'est marina c'est ma mère ces
mammifères qui se foutent de leur
téléphoner maintenant j'en ai pas parce
que la maman et plus ah bah oui à bas
bruit on l'appelle le colonel d'accord a
bien passion d'auteur alors pas ses
auteurs le sortir mais je vais sortir le
mur mamie rouaire voilà deux qui at on
envie de parler de kim ki moon
parler j'avais envie de ne pas faire
preuve de trop d'hypocrisie
moi j'ai le fantasme de la littérature
mais je suis pas un très très grand
lecteur mais j'ai soif
j'ai soif de savoir j'ai soif de
curiosité j'ai soif de m'intéresser
et donc il ya cinq ans que cela ma ma
chérie m'a offert l'oeuvre complète dans
la recherche du temps perdu de marcel
proust et donc je lui demandais pourquoi
tu m'offres ça il me dit c'est pas
compliqué kit quitte à taper une oeuvre
complète au temps au temps de taper
l'oeuvre d'un des deux plus grands
génies de la littérature du xxème siècle
à lui il ya céline alors voilà longtemps
je me suis couché de bonne heure et puis
et puis après j'ai découvert myspace
youtube live store non mais qu'est ce
que tu es ce que vous avez trouvé dans
proust pour l'instant jeu pour l'instant
je suis pas allé jusqu'à la fin du côté
de chez swann
donc on est dans l'ombre des jeunes
filles en fleur qui restent encore bien
la route et les huit volumes 1 et 2 du
côté de guermantes jusqu'à temps
retrouvé non mais je
pour l'instant c'est assez difficile le
feu dans le canton n'a pas les yeux qui
sont faits pour quand on a pas aussi la
tête qui est fait pour lire ses c'est
vrai je suis relativement hermétique
pour l'instant à à proust
je comprends pas tout j'ai tendance
souvent quand je n'arrive pas à dormir
apprendre apprendre le bouquin et sa
maman dort très bien c'est un très bon
somnifère
mais mais j'ai conscience que quand
j'aurai était il a mis toute une vielle
écrire donc ça fait toute une vie à lire
aussi tout simplement et je trouve que
c'est une parce qu'une bonne forme de
respect par rapport à mars elle est ce
qu'elle prend des nouvelles de son
cadeau temps en temps a dit alors août
aurait elle se fout de ma gueule tout le
temps b que dans une émission de
dans une émission de télé me dis alors
bret easton ils ont pensé quoi michael
je l'écouté lunaire parc j'ai vraiment
trouvé ça formidable
elle sait très bien et j'ai lu la fiche
de lecture parce que je voulais crâne et
en télévision
et voilà ce soir bas les masques je
voulais dire que comme moi 18 lui ni
badge voilages les voilà j'ai même pas
fini du côté de chez swann voilà c'est
tout bon merde c'est pas grave on sommes
quand même prêt à lui daniel picouly non
plus récemment look orange de petits
miroirs bombe à marcel attendra un peu
marcel attendre un petit peu pour
l'instant il est bien occupée je crois
que là cette recherche du temps perdu
donc pas sur d'auteur c'était un le
marcel proulx ce2 michaël youn journal
intime alors le journal intime et voit
la petite caméra
bon j'avais lutté rivaliser
d'ingéniosité dans cette terre c'est
comme ça on est comme ça
alors y at il à un moment où si tu as
des poils dans le nord on veille à tous
les détails dans cette émission
s'il ya un moment que michaël youn
aimerait faire partager un moment
d'intimité à un moment de sa vie
de son quotidien
alors qu'est ce que c'est c'est un
souvenir d'enfance quand j'avais quand
j'avais 6 ans mon père qui travaillait
beaucoup qui auraient pas souvent
l'occasion de s'occuper de moi m'avait
emmené un mercredi au jardin
d'acclimatation et il m'avait offert un
ballon de baudruche savez c'est ballon
gonflé gonflé à l'hélium et vous tenez à
part avec un boa ci voulait lâcher il
s'envole
c'était mon premier ballon de baudruche
j'étais fier comme un bar tabac et puis
et puis un coup de vent et le ballon
s'est envolé et alors tout de suite mon
père a vu que jal est complètement
désemparé il a vu que j'allais craquer
il est retourné vers le jardin
d'acclimatation pour m'en acheter un
autre
mais le jardin venait de fermer il n'a
pas vu il est rentré il est revenu vers
moi et m'a dit bah nan c'est pas grave
c'était qu'un ballon michael est là le
vent avait emmené le ballon
pas si loin que ça c'est à dire qu'il
était presque à portée de main quoi il
était on va dire une trentaine de mètres
il était passion dans le ciel je me
disais que c'était encore possible en
sautant très très haut de 2 de le
rattraper et là j'ai dû courir pendant
cinq minutes pendant cinq ou six ans m
l'éditeur je devais avoir 6 ans pour
essayer d'attraper ce ballon et j'ai
jamais pu le rattraper et j'ai craqué
complètement après je crois que j'ai
pleuré toute la soirée et se trouve que
c'est une anecdote qui me caractérise
beaucoup l'eau fait de voilà de courir
derrière ce ballon et je crois qu'encore
aujourd'hui je cours derrière le ce
ballon de l'enfance sport de peut-être
je sais pas de rattraper mon innocence
et je sais pas si je vais y a
la belle image ne sais pas je vous
laisse seul si si si si j'en suis jugé
eh bien on en sait maintenant je crois
un peu plus sur mikari butin peu plus
différemment voilà un peu décalé et
c'était quand même le but de tout ça
merci beaucoup et très plaisir de le
revoir à tous merci à tous
à
[Musique]